it's not that you can't pray or you
don't need to pray
be straight up be honest be a man be a
woman say with your chest you don't want
to pray
and that's okay to feel like that
sometimes but you have to understand
that's a problem
as we always say the biggest problem a
person can have is not knowing they have
a problem to begin with
as long as you acknowledge it's an issue
then you can start to work on
welcome back to the t3m podcast ladies
and gentlemen
it's your host fired with rami and angel
he might be that way uh how's it going
guys
alhamdulillah doing well man how are you
could be better bro why
why are you so sad what happened uh we
got we got
a very important topic today salah
meditation you know being present
connecting to allah
that sort of thing and man i feel like
you all are definitely more in tune with
that than me
and you guys know how much i love
stealing the stealing the show
and holding the floor so i guess it
won't be one for me
all right that's fair that's why you
wear the the fancy sweater today
mentioned i was about to say that's a
nice sweater man it is really nice man
yeah it was a gift yeah i also heard you
guys
i said i also heard you have a very nice
jean jacket masha allah
oh the denim jacket and that was also
gifts bro
two very special people okay bismuth
because it's it's the more important one
so as as human beings we're
uh we thrive off of you know
connections i'd say right and salah
literally
or the root word of salah um literally
means connection
all right so when we pray our salah
we're connecting with allah
and there's a very beautiful hadith with
the prophet sallallahu alaihi
which means that he starts by saying
allah the most high has said
that the most beloved acts to me the
most beloved acts of worship to me are
those which i made obligatory the ones
that i made for
the ones you have to do so allah made
them obligatory because he loves them so
much because
of how a part of me i assume how
beneficial they are to us as human
beings
so the most important relationship any
human being could have
any servant of god could have would be
with the master himself would be with
allah himself
since everything in life comes from
allah and everything returns to allah
as as humans we need that connection
with allah is it's the connecting
force right it's the bridge to our
belief and it's it's the
means in which we worship allah i would
say on a grand scale because it's the
most beloved acts of worship to allah
and the hadith goes on to say and then
the servant gets closer and closer and
closer to allah
with voluntary acts of good here and
there until allah begins to love the
servant until allah begins to love that
slave
so we could see how crucial what allah
made
is right specifically salah because we
pray five times a day
and originally it was supposed to be
what 500 or something like that
because of the prophet i sent him when
he went to the night journey
allah prescribed i think 500 prayers or
so and then
he met musa alayhis salaam and musa
moses peace upon him said
your nation won't be able to handle that
listen i was there i
i dealt with the nation and they're not
going to be able to you know deal with
that
go back to allah ask them to reduce it
the prophet said it went to allah again
and then allah reduced it and this
happened a few times till it went down
to five
but it kept the value that it was
supposed to originally
keep that in mind we were supposed to
pray something insane like 50 or 500
prayers a day
something insane it kept that value but
it went down to five
which is how merciful allah is so this
is the value of our prayer
five times a day and it's connecting us
with allah a lot of us including myself
struggle with being focused in prayer
but it it's like this conversation we're
having if my words didn't have meaning
to you
or to me then this conversation would
with one of us
would just be relatively useless because
the meaningless words
have no meaning that's why they're
meaningless so if you say alhamdulillah
but you don't know what the heck you're
saying you don't know what the heck it
means then it's meaningless to you
you're not gonna have that focus it's
just like any conversation connection
you're having with somebody
sometimes you feel like you're talking
to a wall because they're just not
paying attention to you
right so when you're saying
alhamdulillah you have to know what
you're saying you have to know you're
saying
praise glory is to allah the lord of
everything that exists
that's a very profound statement and
it's not a reminder to allah it's a
reminder to us that's why we're saying
it
so you have to know what you're saying
in prayer you have to know who you're
praying to
you have to know why you're praying and
you have to know how important it is
that's why i started this with the
hadith of the prophet
where he said the most beloved acts of
worship to allah are those which he made
obligatory
i like that
like that bro i would even go as far as
to say um
i'm gonna add to it because it's
something that i i saw in a video where
this guy now i wish i could remember his
name right now
but um he said that
you have salah which is isn't prayer
it's it's worship
and then you have dua which is prayer
whereas i pray
you're like asking for something for
either for yourself or
someone else or for something to happen
and then when you do salat like you were
just
worshiping the creator with nothing like
you're not asking for anything in return
you're just
worshiping the creator because he's he
deserves all worship
he doesn't need it but he deserves it
yeah i think that's
i think that's beautiful yeah subhan
allah it truly is
allah and it's amazing because there are
actually benefits of praying salah just
the movements that we
you know do on a daily basis just making
will do it before prayer
all these things have you know amazing
benefits even
i i saw this one post i can't remember
exactly so take what the grain of salt
but i saw this one post of a woman
who's basically prostrating her elbows
are on the floor but she's basically
prostrating
and it the post said something like
i don't want to say anything wrong right
i remember it saying something about
covid but i'm not going to say anything
that i don't know for sure
but it is a relatively good position to
be in
if you're if you're speaking in sense of
you know your body and your bodily
health
it is good don't think of it like a yoga
position i wanted to say that but i'm
not going to say that
it's not a yoga position but just being
in certain movements in certain
positions is good for your body
alhamdulillah and that's just a physical
aspect i had a quick i had a quick
rebuttal bro
just to play devil's advocate i get this
a lot of time uh
from you know guys and girls they're
just like hey i'm a really good muslim
or i try to be
insha allah like i i you know i fast
when it's ramadan
i give charity i even you know spread
dawah sometimes i like
i i know about a lot i research about
allah i uh
i meditate but i don't need to pray like
i could do all these things and i don't
need to do salah
you know why why do i need to do that
one thing why can't i connect to allah
in my own way
all right well i love to use this
example
let's say you had a person who who did
everything amazingly right they were
amazing to every person they always gave
in charity
they always helped everybody but this
person was a piece of trash when it came
to their parents right they
treated their parents like they even
abused their parents is this person
still a good person no they can't be a
good person
because anybody we just have this innate
love for the parents right this innate
respect for the parents
and imagine now the innate respect you
should have for allah
where when allah makes something
obligatory you should do it
and when allah says make something haram
then you should stay away from it so now
imagine saying i'm doing everything i'm
such a good person
except one of the things that i must be
doing that i'm not doing
right for example we're respecting the
parents something you have to do if
you're not doing that
if you're doing the opposite how are you
a good person how do you have the
audacity to call yourself a good person
so imagine now denying what allah has
said
it's it's it's two contradictory
statements say i'm a good muslim
i don't pray i'm fully green
or i'm fully red you you can't have both
so that's the that's where the fault
comes in and i feel i don't want to be
rude to anybody but i feel like
a lot of it comes from laziness right
it's it's just
like anil was saying before this call
justifying certain things in your head
to make it okay
it's just justifying it justifying your
laziness essentially
it's not that you can't pray or you
don't need to pray
be straight up be honest be a man be a
woman say with your chest you don't want
to pray
and that's okay to feel like that
sometimes but you have to understand
that's a problem
as we always say the biggest problem a
person can have is not knowing they have
a problem to begin with
as long as you acknowledge it's an issue
then you can start to work on it so
as long as you go and say okay i i you
know i have a
shortcoming i fall short and i'm
supposed to be praying but i'm not
then that's okay but you can't be a good
muslim
if you're not doing what a good muslim
does
dude and people would say like oh well
i can connect to god without prayer
and it's like yeah sure sure you can i
mean i speak from my personal experience
before i came to islam
yeah like i was doing dopamine detox i
felt very
in tune very connected to god but you
wanna know what like
the way life works is that it's always
pulling us away
from god it's always pulling us away
from the straight path so it's like
dude that's a lot is keeping you on
point this light is keeping you on the
straight path
and it's like like rami said in the
beginning you say alhamdulillah
and you say it as a reminder to yourself
you don't say it for
allah allah doesn't need you to say
alhamdulillah
that's for you you say it for yourself
and also as well for others around you
because you're saying praise be to god
or a praise be to the creator
so it's like it's just a reminder and
that's what salah is and
you know like again can you do it
without i mean from personal experience
yeah but that's like going in the dark
and then trying to find your way like
can you do it yet but is it the most
effective
way to do it no yeah subhan allah just
to piggyback that point
masha allah it's it's kind of like
reaching out to any person right if i
say the best way to contact me is email
and you're blowing up my phone that's
not the best way to contact me i'm not
gonna answer i'm not gonna respond to
that i told you
i told you as a as an individual the
best way to contact me is through email
therefore do it i'm more responsive
there maybe i'm in a better mood when
i'm checking my email as opposed to my
phone
because i don't like people blowing up
my phone whatever it is allah says
that praying five times a day is fart
and it is the best
most beloved acts of worship to him this
is something allah loves
why would you not do it you it listen
allah doesn't need you you need him
right you need to connect to him because
if you move from allah
or if one moves from the other it's
always you're moving from allah because
allah is
the ultimate allah doesn't move allah
doesn't need to move allah is
all-powerful right he can't
like be weak in a sense of his his
connection with you is weak
it's that you connecting with him is
weak it's not there on your end so if
allah says pray
and you don't then you're not connecting
with him in the best possible way
so i think that was a good point masha
allah bless you strong man
y'all heard this thing called love
languages
yes where it's like in psychology to
have this thing where it's like
everyone has one of these six love
languages or something like that
and it's like and you were telling me
about this in iceland
yeah it's like there's a physical
intimacy there's
acts of service there's a quality time
there's uh i think it was something like
uh spending like giving them gifts
yeah and everyone has one that they're
more dominant in
and it's like when you're with your wife
or husband or
you know you you wanna you wanna get
them happy you wanna please them you
wanna get close to them
you wanna emotionally i guess connect to
them if you're out here doing things
that's not gonna be there it's like yeah
they might still value it but they won't
value
it as much as their love language so if
you have a girl
who's your wife and she really likes
let's say
quality time you're out here buying her
chanel purses
gucci purses louis vuitton you got her
you know head to toe and designer
she might not appreciate as much as you
just spending one hour of
being present with her with nothing else
whereas if you have
some materialistic one and you're out
here trying to you know
get her heart she doesn't want that so
what i'm trying to
where i'm trying to go with this is
allah tells you in allah ordains for us
the one thing that we could do to get
closest to him and worship him
and it's salah and you're out here
saying no i don't want to do salah i
want to do something else i wanna
i wanna you know astral project or
whatever stuck for allah all these
things or i wanna
i wanna meditate and only do that
there's nothing wrong with meditation
but allah literally specifies just like
angel says
islam and the quran is the instruction
manual
you're out here like oh i like the
instruction manual but i feel like it
should be like this
and it's like bro you got to realize
your place in the universe you don't
call these shots
and it's it's okay like that like that's
mainly the point of this talk will help
you guys get to the five daily prayers
insha'allah
we'll tell you about steps to overcome
it how i did it how rami did it
um you know how angel's doing it what
what we're doing in the process to get
to that point
because you don't go from praying zero
times a day to five and rami
rami said that multiple times you go
from zero to one
and praying one yeah you might think
okay i'm still not doing four prayers
it's still better than praying nothing
and then slowly go to two to three to
four to five
that's about a lot
some people can't jump to five some
people can um
but the only issue is when they think
they should be able to and then they
can't
they they feel discouraged so just bless
ultimately by the way i thought it was
five
because i i i saw an ayatollah video he
was referencing a secular
reference and he was tying in with the
sunnah and he said you can find these
five in the sunnah
and uh if i remember correctly it was i
think you mentioned five
there's physical intimacy there's words
that's why he said speech
gift giving time and he said money or
something like that
um wait say that one more time so
physical
yeah okay go north inshallah so physical
intimacy
speech words of love so words of
affirmation yeah what else
yeah yeah um gift giving you mentioned
that give giving
quality time you mentioned that quality
time and there's some oh yeah um
uh you said acts of service and like
helping out that's serious yeah
that's those are the five that i could
think of i thought it was six if there's
five subhanallah
yeah okay just wanted to make sure it
makes it easier for you all then yeah if
there's one that i'm missing i need to
get on that inshallah
like one i like to receive yeah which is
the
your uh the language that y'all
i like five out of five bro no i'm
playing i like quality time the most
because i feel like we live in a world
where no one's present everyone's just
on their phone or worrying about
something else or stressing
and i feel like quality time really
shows that someone cares bro
and just just to go off on a little mini
point right now before y'all tell me
yours
the act the the love language that you
have that you like to receive
is not the same that you got to give so
in psychology they always say that let's
say for me i like quality time
if i'm with someone that doesn't like
quality time and i'm only giving quality
time because that's what i like to
receive
it she won't feel as valued as if she
likes let's say
words of affirmation and i notice that
i'm cognizant of that and i give her
that and vice versa if she
likes words of affirmation and she's
always reaffirming me
of some next ish and i'm here like bro i
want acts of service
so then you know what i mean so i would
say
i'm in between quality time and acts of
service
i know you're wrong you go first you go
first no i don't know bro
i asked the question so okay that's only
just
right that's fair um i don't really know
to be honest
i would say i'm not experienced enough
to really fully know uh and i'm just
being brutally honest
um they all sound nice um i've always
been a person you know who enjoyed
thoughtful gifts right like i don't i
don't care much from materialistic
things
but thoughtful gifts which i feel like
tight that ties into quality time
because i know they they put time aside
to do that and it has
meaning there's more um acts of service
acts of service
is a separate one from actual service
yeah about true okay
i feel like it ties in to uh quality
time yeah
they kind of put the thought in that's
that's true but what if they give you
that gift and then they're like peace
then i throw the gift out and say peace
no no no i'm saying like they give you
the gift
they really thought about it they took
out the time to get you that gift it was
very thought out
but they're like yo here's the gift i
gotta go though i gotta go to work i was
no i was actually in that situation
because i don't know if i told you but
back when i i tried to get married once
it was it was a lot of i'm not here
but on the birthday here's a super
amazing gift like it was really
thoughtful it was expensive and it was
thoughtful
like i'm literally talking like an
entire printer
size like handwritten size 8 font
landscape mode just freaking going all
out little notes little cards
uh printed pictures of us explosion box
with candies and chocolates
and i'm like i'm talking go they went
all out little queen
bro and it's like it's like yo you're
doing all these things you're doing the
most on like the one day of the year
what are you doing 364 days a year
that's that's the issue because i i
heard it was um
a gift dumping that's what somebody
called it when they felt guilty about
not that's what i'm saying
fellas fellas if you're slipping on
valentine's day
just just just tell your woman this how
do you treat you right
364 days of the year what i got to do
this one day
i bet you a lot of chicks are gonna
respond to that in the comments
if you're a man you should treat me
right every day
get out yeah you need to but if if i had
to
pick one though it would be the physical
yeah and physical is not just like
intercourse guys i just wanted to get
that out there like
some some like sometimes it's just
holding hands or just anything like
you know it is it is just any physical
intimacy but yeah i i knew that about
you lokiano you look like the handling
type bro
the handling the hand holding handle
then
my moments that handle it handling
do you already know what's going on in
my head but um
what do you expect from a guy grapples
like all day
yeah yeah i was gonna say that remember
we were talking in the in the uh
the messages where it's like oh some
people have the
cognitive recall some people learn
better like cognitively
some people learn better somatically you
know in in
the scientific terminology is uh
kinesthetic learning
but bro like i've always been a physical
person so it's like physically if
i respond best to learning things
physically
i respond best to doing things
physically then it would make sense that
like
the whole love language would also be
physical as well
that's smart that's why yeah um about
about that one point
that that fire you made before you also
called it in that video i forgot what
it's called but it was a really good
video
he mentioned um a lot of women don't
like
even like kissing their man because they
know the only time they get kissed
is when it's gonna progress to the final
stage it's never a man going and just
giving a little
a little smooch smooch just to be nice
it's always let me give you this so i
can get that
in a few minutes
listen it's not it's not any just just
be a player right just be player assault
just be
smooth man and it's not it's not it's
not a soy boy it's not simply to be
smooth with your woman
i don't know i don't i really don't get
this man like sometimes just just
just go at it just you know and then
just leave just did
why does it always have to lead someone
yeah i mean like
at the end of the day i don't know the
way i see it is like i don't
i can do little things to make them
happy even if i'm not really getting
anything out of it because one
my duty islamically i must be kind and
nice
uh and two it has to do with short-term
gratification versus long-term
gratification right let's say you give a
little something here and you're not
really getting much
you're not really getting much in the
moment but if you wait in the long term
the bonds gonna be a lot better
i know we kind of diverted the topic a
little bit uh we started about salah
which is a connection with allah now
we're talking about connecting to your
spouse
i feel like you're always kind of wrong
if you really think about it if you
really think about it allah says
getting married is 50 of your deen yes
so having a wife is like 50
um and then if you do uh on hell's
calculation on how's formula that's like
the mathematical equation
if you have four wives you are
fulfilling 200 percent
of your dean yes the math makes sense
but uh
and you already know he's an
overachiever so in regards to that and
it's so nice to be with your wife so
yeah like i mean physically intimately
be with you all right all right let's
let's put love and women aside for a
minute bro i love
i love how every time we like view off
topic fire finds a way to like connect
it back to the main topic
fire the job is to be the bridge yo we
said that in the beginning didn't we
yeah yeah well what was anna saying uh
like oh no you texted us one day you
gave us like three like rolls what were
they
uh damn dude all i remember is that you
were the bridge
i i mean mommy and you were what i was
like
okay do you remember yeah i do it's um
rami was the
the uh source for the islamic knowledge
and wisdom
and i was the source for like the
secular knowledge and wisdom but you
were the bridge in between both
i feel then some of y'all peeps
commented that down below as well
that something like uh someone's the
alchemist
something like that uh someone's the you
said okay that was you said that uh
rami was a scholar fire was the
alchemist and i was the warrior
different a lot of y'all also commented
down below that name a more iconic duo
than fired and what was it
um
every time someone drops a fact we just
hear a fight in the background
it's actually not like i'm not
consciously making that sound guys i
just want you to know
it's it's the it's the wisdom being
encoded into my long-term
memory for retrieval and that's like the
processing sound that the hardware makes
you guys you just as you remembering
you're remembering something that was
already there
i know i just spit some facts away yeah
bro it's it's essentially just me giving
you some validation bro just a little
bit
i don't want to give it to you you know
i appreciate it
when you very true
very true i'm a very arrogant individual
anyway with that being said let's let's
go back to the point of salah
and then in sha allah we can get some
insight on
meditation from our brother angel
all right bismillah i don't know how
much more i have on han solo to be
honest i kind of
got there bro i feel like some people it
might just be me but
and this is definitely me first because
this used to be me in the past
people don't know and they don't they're
not cognizant of who they're standing in
front of when they're doing salah
they're out here thinking okay allah
wants me to pray they are
nobody denies that nobody denies allah
told us to pray
so they're out here thinking okay cool
i'm praying i got that one little chair
in front of me that's always there in
the room where i got that wall
i already know where it is when i think
of praying that's in front of me but
they don't realize who they're standing
in front of
they don't realize when they prostrate
allah is literally in front of them
and for people that are like oh allah is
out in front of you allah is over there
bro allah says in the holy quran
i am closer to you indeed than your own
jugular vein
so who are you to say that allah is not
close to you allah is literally in front
of us
right in front of you while you're
prostrating while you're in sajuda
while you're in it's like people don't
get that and i didn't get that so for me
yeah i had a relationship with salah not
gonna lie like
when i would pray my life would be good
my life would be straight i would be
getting good marks out like good grades
in school
life would be simple i would have low
stress and mentally i was sound
physically i was sound and when i was it
uh when i wasn't uh prioritizing salah
my life wasn't
as on point but what i'm trying to say
is
that's good and all that's like a
transactional relationship but you still
have salah
in your mind as an act like it's an
activity but you don't realize the
connection with allah you don't realize
you're literally
in front like allah is in front of you
and you're submitting to allah you're
prospering to allah
and when i started doing that it was a
whole mindset shift
i started being in sujood which is
prostrating
way longer like every time i would go
down
i was there for like 10-15 seconds where
before it was just like
lock work but and then i'm back again
you feel me
yeah it's the panel yeah go on
not go ahead bro i feel like mine is
going to be actually hold up
yeah all right now go ahead but i feel
like mine's going to be longer
that's the thing go ahead bro go ahead
and if we analyze the statement of allah
is in front of you
just think about it what does it mean
that you know when you say someone's in
front of you it means they can see you
they can hear you they are close they
are responsive they are
you know whatever capable of this that
the other and if you look at allah he
was always capable of everything and
anything that
is you know obviously possible um
because i don't want people to think
that god ceasing to exist is a
possibility or something
because a lot of christians kind of
confuse that um but that that's a side
note
but when we say allah is in front of you
we're not calling him a physical entity
that is physically here in the universe
but we mean it metaphorically in the
sense that allah is there allah is
listening allah is
uh observing allah knows allah is
responsive and actually when you pray to
allah
i forget the words exactly but when you
say the words and sort of
like allah responds by saying
my servant has praised me and so on and
so forth with everything you say
in the surah allah responds to it
subhanallah
so that's what we mean when we say allah
is in front of you he is observing you
he is aware he is responsive
he knows the only issue is that you
can't see allah or anything like that
and you know a lot of people say oh to
believe i have to see it that's not
necessarily true
by necessity at the end of the day let
me
chime in real quick before anna finally
comes in with this point
uh unless you know after i'm done you
have another point and then we'll we'll
put on those on the back burner again
it's okay though man is all day uh so
what we were gonna say though
is that you guys when you become
cognizant of that when you become aware
of that
it's insane like the the amount of
benefit it brings to you the amount of
presence
like angel says like uh you can get that
through meditation
but it's not comparable see you guys are
out here thinking
okay allah is out there in heaven you
know he has bigger fish to fry he's
he's doing something else and he's not
here worrying about me but
we all know that iblis is simultaneously
with everyone
trying to attack everyone at the same
time eight billion people whatever
if he's doing it why do you think allah
can't do it and on top of that allah
tells you too that
don't ever think that you're you're
committing a sin with two
in a room except i'm the third or that
you're in a room with your
you guys are doing something with three
people except on the fourth see
we're out here with two people let's say
there's three people here and we're
trying to rob someone and
they can't see allah and they're like
okay cool i'm just the three of us
cool nah bro allah says he's the fourth
allah is always watching
don't now be paranoid with that and be
you know be walking on eggshells but ask
yourself why should
you be living a life that you don't want
a lot to be watching anyway
yeah yeah yeah and bro like some people
will be like
all right well i'm doing this a lot
but i don't really feel anything it's
like okay well
two things here man number one
that's where your imagination comes into
play and it sucks that i have to say
that but it's like as a little kid a
little kid doesn't have to try
to imagine anything like they just do
it's a part of them
uh once we grow up for some reason our
imagination
becomes uh pretty bad and it's a pretty
terrible word to use imagination because
that would imply that it's
it's not real but in reality it's super
real
because also like if you understand from
a psychological perspective
the subconscious mind you could say
something you could do something you
could dream something and like
well your subconscious mind doesn't know
what's real from what's not real
so like then that should in and of
itself tell you okay
then it's not imaginary all right but
what i'm trying to say is like
it all boils down to like how sensitized
are you
because if you're desensitized like
let's say you're spending all day on
electronics
all day on the computer all day on your
phone
all day watching videos all day reading
all day
talking with people are they doing
things where it's like
i well now when you're doing something
so simple
as to worship the creator where you're
just like putting everything aside
and you're just you're making this time
out to just be 100 present with the
creator and to worship the creator
you can't even do that you can't even do
that because you're desensitized you
either
can't be 100 present because you're over
here uh
thinking about this this and that or you
know
you can be president you just don't
really feel anything man
it's like i've said where you do a
dopamine detox
and in the beginning of the dopamine
detox where you're like super
desensitized you walk outside you see a
butterfly flying
you don't notice the butterfly but then
three four weeks later
after you're sensitized you walk outside
you see this butterfly you're like damn
mashallah
so it all boils back into
are you sensitized are you actually able
to be a 100
president are you actually able to be
fully there
in your salah and then again
if we don't want to refer to it as
imagination we'll say
are you able to step down
because that's what it is like the only
time that you experience the creator is
when you step down or at least
from my personal experience it if i have
my ego up
if i'm like being arrogant or if i'm
like feeling some type of way or
thinking about something
dude like i don't feel dude i don't feel
creative i'll do salat and it's like i'm
just going through the motions
but if i step down well then that's a
different story
all right subhanallah i think this is
why some scholars recommend or some
people recommend that
a person takes five minutes before
praying just to clear their thoughts
because i forgot i forgot what she said
this but if you go from like playing a
video game
to praying right away and sometimes
we're rushing we have to do that
but if you do that then you're not
really thinking about allah you're not
thinking a prayer you're still thinking
about the game your mind is still on the
game
and i find this with myself whenever i
stop doing anything and i go to pray
my mind is still on that thing so let's
i think this is a good transitional
point into meditation because it seems
that meditating
for a few minutes before prayer is
really good to get your mind
calm enough to be able to focus on
prayer so do you want to elaborate on
that on hell
yes sir so i was about to say like what
the sheep just said
when you take five minutes to just clear
your thoughts like that's meditation in
and of itself
so a lot of people will say uh well oh
meditation is bad
it's it's not that meditation is bad and
i was talking to
a sister on instagram about this i do
not remember her name actually i don't
even know how to say anything
but um and meditation is neutral
wasn't it sonia
is the one that's after rami bro
you know that you know that but um
it's meditation is neutral and at the
end of the day it's up to us
whether we are going to use it for good
or whether we're going to use it for bad
or it's like if you think about it
meditation is just
fixated attention right like right now
we're talking to each other right now
we're paying attention to each other
this is like meditation and another
stuff
i mean not to the greatest degree but
into a certain extent like
if you sit down and you close your eyes
you're taking your sense of sight out of
the equation
which only gives you four sites to work
with and
with taste you're probably not tasting
anything so now you just have three
three senses to work with you got
feeling you got hearing
and you got smelling all right so if
you're outside in nature you can
activate those three senses and
really pay attention to those three
senses and
because you're taking two senses out of
the equation you make it a lot easier
for you
to get into a meditative state in a
meditative state
would just be a state of fixated
attention
now things start getting bad when people
use meditation
with a certain intention of oh i'm
meditating to have an
out-of-body experience i'm meditating to
uh
do remote viewing like how we were
talking about fire
i'm meditating to uh
i don't know for just simple example
purpose i'm meditating to be more
present so that i can dominate other
people
like that that's kind of it's kind of a
sus
if you think about it but if you're
meditating with the soul intention of
okay let me
meditate so i can be more present and so
i can be more in tune with
myself or better yet with the creator
with everyone around me with myself with
nature
with life in and of itself because like
yo it's good to
think it's good to like have things
going on in your head but like
are you really living your life if
you're spending
99 of time up here and one percent of
time
here in the present and it's like you
got to think to yourself
like where are you going to feel the
creator the most where are you going to
find the creator the most
in your thoughts in your head or in the
present
i mean yeah the creator is omniscient
the creator is everywhere
so like even if you're stuck in your
head the creator can still reach you you
can still experience the creator you can
still
feel the creator and like some people
will experience signs and
i'm saying that loosely because i'm just
referring to myself
primarily where it's like i'll see i'll
see numbers where it's like okay that's
that's definitely something that's like
waking me up because i'm like stuck in
my head
i'm just i'm not present i'm stuck in my
head and it's like this number pops up
all the time for me and when i see that
it's like oh well what does that number
do
what does that sign do specifically for
me
does it bring me even further into my
head or is it bringing me into the
present that's what you gotta think if
the creator can be experienced most in
the present
and when you are stuck in your head
something whether you hear something see
something smell something
feel something whatever it is and it
snaps you out of your head where does it
bring you
to the present moment because that is
where you're going to experience the
creator the most
and when you meditate it only it only
makes a lot even better
i mean you basically pay attention more
and that's actually beautiful i know
because allah does say that if you
if you're looking for signs of us
they're everywhere just look around you
and allah also says that
um you know when we're fasting for
ramadan
we're not supposed to pray maghrib
without breaking our fast
this is very sunnah we have to break our
fast first
if we have to if we have to pray
inshallah
and we got dinner and we're in a fork in
the road we're instructed to eat dinner
first
because if you pray isha your mind's
going to be on food your mind's going to
be thinking with the food
you're gonna be just just in your head
you're just gonna be anticipating
something after
the salah you're not gonna be in the
salah
present in the moment so i'm not saying
guys go get everything done and then
you know do do once and pray all five no
that's not what i'm saying
i'm saying pray throughout the day on
time but
if there's something impeding you from
maximizing
how present you feel tackle that out of
the way first get it done asap
and then you know praise a lot then go
back to it but if it's something you
know
that that's major like you know it's
gonna take three four hours okay no then
pray salah first
yeah and if people are wondering like
okay how do i meditate now that you're
saying all this
dude just sit down sit down close your
eyes and just
pay attention pay attention to your
breathing
pay attention to whatever thoughts start
coming up in your head
pay attention to whatever you're hearing
in the background you could hear maybe
some cars in the distance
you could hear maybe your family like
moving around talking doing stuff like
you don't need to be in a quiet
environment matter of fact if you're in
an environment where it's like really
noisy
that's even better bro because it gives
you more
stimulus to pay attention to and like
the fact here is fixated attention
but like you imagine you have a muscle
right you have your bicep you go to the
gym
you do a chin up or you do a bicep curl
you are activating
the bicep right that is conscious
activation of the bicep now when you're
doing
certain things throughout the day you're
activating your biceps because
you're using your entire body throughout
the day but that's that's an
unconscious action you're unconsciously
activating your bicep
and you being present is like a muscle
so it's like
yeah you have the ability to be present
without meditating
you can meditate without even knowing
you're meditating but it's like if you
train yourself
every single day if you meditate every
single day
you're just increasing your ability to
be able to be present
to be able to like okay i can i can now
activate this bicep
100 times better than before like you're
telling me if a dude who can only bicep
curl
um a 10 pound dumbbell versus a guy who
can
dumbbell curl an 80 pound dumbbell
you're talking
you're gonna tell me that the
unconscious activation of that bicep
in the person who can only curl 10
pounds is going to be stronger than the
unconscious activation
of the bicep and dude that can curl 80
pounds
come on bravo someone reached out with a
similar question they're like
i can only and it was to a music and
substance use
um episode they were like how do i how
do i work out without music how do i
and so guys i've started doing that for
the last couple months
and yeah you guys know what i mean you
can't work out without music
it's impossible because best believe if
you got nothing in your ears the music
is still playing from the gym they got
something on
on full blast so what i mean is i don't
have my tracks anymore i just go into
the gym
sometimes like i work out without any
music at all because the gym
itself sometimes they just don't play
music it's just the one i'm lucky enough
to have that but
the amount of mind muscle connection
activation that ana's talking about that
i feel without music
is uncomparable compared to music where
it's like when i'm when i have music
i'm kind of like rhythmically doing my
sets i'm waiting for the beat to drop
then i'm going in
and i'm kind of dependent on that i'm
relying on that whereas the amount of
presence i feel
i'm proactive when i'm there without
anything without any thoughts in my mind
when i got no music on not reactive
yeah and that's well that's where it
like ties in again
with the whole uh dopamine aspect that i
was talking about
was like dude just simplify your life or
cis just simplify your life
dudes dudes and dudettes it's like your
life
you were not created to be doing all the
things that you're doing
um yes it's a blessing that we have
technology and we can do all these
things but
just simplify your life and you'll see
like how much more in tune how much more
mind muscle connection
you'll feel you know referring to the
example here
[Music]
subhanallah i feel like on that point
it's a bit unrelated but it is related
in a sense brought me real quick before
you go what's the time right now
148. perfect all right
i feel like with technology social media
and seeing other people's lives and and
having a very specific perception of our
own selves and our own
lives um we're never content right
we're never content we always there's
always something we want
but it's kind of like an undefined goal
right
like imagine you want to make money
right you want to make you want to hit a
goal
of making a certain amount of money but
you don't have a defined amount of money
you want to make
you're never going to stop that rat race
you're never going to stop trying to get
more and if you never hit that goal
because it's undefined
right and it's like infinite regression
again um
it basically puts you in a state where
okay you can never be content
because the beautiful thing about
contentment
is happiness is in the definition so i
feel like
people shouldn't look for happiness they
should just find contentment
because if you look for happiness you
may never actually find it
because you're searching for this thing
that's like where is happiness
it's in the definition of contentment so
once a person is content with their
salah with who they are with their life
with whatever simplistic way they're
living once they're content with that
then they'll find happiness within
themselves within the definition
and this is something we we shy away
from because nowadays we have people on
instagram who are posting
i'm you know i just gained 30 pounds of
muscle in the last
x amount of time or i just lost x amount
of weight or look i just got this new
car
look i have a freaking only fans and i'm
20 and i just bought a house and it's
like
what like when does it stop for us and
the thing is it never stops because as
humans we always want more the
prosthetic sedum said if you give a
person a mountain of gold they're just
gonna want another mountain of gold
but when you take away the love of the
mountain of gold
then you're just left with yourself and
when you're left with yourself
then you're left with a sense of
contentment as i don't need anything
else
it's beautiful i mean man yeah just to
end off in sha allah
um the only time having materialistic
things are good
is when it reminds you of allah because
there's a beautiful verse in surah saud
where sulaiman alayhi saddam solomon
peace be upon him
before allah gave him the kingdom that
he gave him
he says i'm in love with these things
out of the remembrance of my lord and
that's the mentality you should have
when you pray
i love praying out of the remembrance of
allah
i love fasting out of the remembrance of
allah i love
working and making money and and seeing
all these beautiful things wife kids
family
wives kids family whatever so on and so
forth
i love these things out of gratitude and
remembrance of allah
and at the end of the day if you have
that you will find contentment as allah
says in the quran
indeed with my remembrance their hearts
find ease they find contentment
i mean man and just bro just to address
your point of
you know you bought a house with only
fans and you wanna do this
baby girl go do your thing we're not
gonna judge
over here it's your life it's you know
you do what you want but
best believe if you're living life with
recruit difficulty in this dunya
you're gonna be living you know some
other life with the extreme difficulty
and the hereafter and allah doesn't just
call it the day of judgment allah calls
it day of recompense
where every soul will be repaid in full
for good or for bad
and at the end of the it's your life man
think about it
but anha we got 10 minutes on the clock
all right fourth quarter right now let's
talk about one
last topic and i think it's very
important and it kind of ties into what
we did so far
let's talk about psychedelics
before we even say that how much y'all
want to bet that there's going to be
some woman that's going to respond to
what ramen just said saying oh well
if we should be content and not seek
happiness then you should be content
with one wife
well here's the difference guys at the
end of the day
and and take it as you go we got a lot
of self-proclaimed feminists
in the comment section and they're also
they're muslim too
at least they identify as muslims and
believers you can't be a feminist
like a modern day feminist and a muslim
at the same time like it doesn't work
you could be an idealistic feminist like
what they preach for as in
we both have equal value in the eyes of
allah
and be a muslim of course bro but you
are here saying
gender roles don't exist and we you know
men are trying to
women have to be men and men got to be
women now bro that's that's not islam
you got it messed up just to respond to
the the point that some
some feminists are going to make uh the
difference is the goal
for a lot of people with only fans is to
make money
right but my goal is not to have four
wives that's not a goal
if i'm able i'll do it whatever it's
actually just a means to achieving the
goal of pleasing allah
because the more women that are married
the less haram take place
with me and with them the more kids
muslim kids we could have the more
but that will come from and this is
something
objectively true from god god would
objectively say that only fans is haram
you should dish it out you should dash
it away
that's the difference between your
subjective goals and
into as an individual and my
understanding of the objective morality
god has given us
so it's subject at the end of the day
yeah
love doesn't make you know only fans and
you know
you know going outside and this is for
the ladies going outside basically
dressed in nothing
and you know all this haram for no
reason you didn't just pull it out of
thin air
it's hard on because it violates your
soul it violates your and you know i
don't want to get too much into the look
because we will have a special guest
feature from sapience institute
and ayura coming over on the next
episode inshallah
and he is a master um at least relative
to us alhamdulillah
you will go into islamic uh you know
talking about
and talking about our soul islamic soul
and all that so
without going into that it really does
violate your souls uh ladies a lot
prescribes and ordains these things for
you because it's like when you start
getting
hooked into that validation you can now
no longer
live your life without that validation
you can now no longer
you know go a couple months without
posting a picture or
you know whatever posting on your
private snap or going outside dressed in
whatever to get that attention because
you now need it and now it's like your
self-esteem your basic self-worth
in the eyes of allah in the eyes of
anyone is basically based off of that
and it's not right and it's
self-perceived it's self-created and
it's self-destructive
whereas the girls i know that don't need
that they don't rely on that
they're out here straight like they
don't fold they're out here being proper
women and respectable women and allah
will
definitely recompense them fairly but
rami
now now that you know we went on this
round we got we got five minutes left
what's the time right now
yeah it's 1 55. yeah we're gonna have to
leave the uh
the psychedelics we'll make psychedelics
and
its own episode and uh let me see but
what do you got to say i want to throw
some in yeah real quick i'll let you all
let you speak and then real quick i want
to make a point on psychedelics and
how it kind of forces you to be in the
present moment without actually
developing
the i guess developing developing your
fit or developing your inner soul
to achieve their state of presence yes
like steroids
yeah all right so um referring to
psychedelics man like that's
there's so much to talk on that so like
i'd rather make a separate video than
just try to
cram it into a few minutes but um
just to answer some of the women out
there who
would question like oh why would a man
want four wives like
well me personally like
i wanna i wanna be able to have multiple
kids
and i wanna be able to develop these
kids into like the highest value
uh men and women muslim
humans on this earth you know like i'm
not trying to like coach through this
i'm not trying to like
have no mediocre kids i'm not trying to
do it for the giggles and everything
like
i'm trying to create some super muslims
some superhuman muslims here bro
and like it's serious bro and it's if
the girl has to go through pregnancy
the girl has to go through how many
months is it is it is it nine
i believe nine and a half they have to
go through nine and a half months
of pregnancy and then give birth and
like but they they have all these things
where it's like okay
when a woman gives birth it's like the
most painful thing ever
where is like a man will never come to
experience yo let me pause you real
quick we're studying this in obstetrics
and gynecology right now that
it's not even nine and a half months g
it's nine and a half months for delivery
but after that bro for
up to several months she's out of
commission bro
yeah best believe plus one plus years
yeah bro and i'm i'm not even talking
about
i'm not even talking about a sexual
relationship i'm talking
more so in the fact and i think that's
what you were referring to as well yeah
i'm talking about just
bodily recovery yeah but you you see
where my mind is i'm over here just
thinking about
sexual relations but um this girl
right so she's um she has to go nine and
a half months
to be pregnant and then give birth like
all right
are you going to be doing this back to
back are you going to be having a kid
after a kid after a kid after a kid
and also on top of that like are you an
a1
chick like do you feel the uh
the role of being a top-notch woman like
are you a high-value woman like yeah
as a man we have to be high value but as
a woman are you high value
like are you are you doing it for me or
for the man that you're gonna be with
to such a degree that he wouldn't need
another woman
in any regard and if you are then
i feel like that's when monogamy
would be uh a hundred percent ideal even
if the man could uh afford
to have multiple wives if the woman can
like show her worth and like be such
high value and be such a part of the
team that she's like
willing to do all this for he's like yo
he doesn't need any like that's that's
the only time that i'll see like
monogamy as like a legitimate thing
as a super permissible thing even if you
have the means to
have more lives but it let's be honest
y'all like
we are not perfect men are not perfect
women are not perfect so it's like for a
woman to be
that top-notch that unicorn bro it is
0.0001 so it's
not that it's not real but it's it's
just that it's very
before you all come and attack us yeah
bro before you guys come and attack us
and moana is saying right now and
putting words into now basically look at
the statistics pull up the number of men
alive today and the number of women
alive today there's way more women than
men i'm not saying it's like a
80 to 20 ratio but it's definitely in 50
50
and it's because men are dying at
disproportionately higher rates than
women
they work dangerous jobs they work at
riskier environments
they die more in battle and war and when
you look at these stats you begin to and
suicide rates are higher too
you look at that it's like if only one
man was only for one woman
they'd be a lot of unmarried women and
it would open these women up to
promiscuity and haram and zina and all
that no matter what you want to say just
violation of their soul like we talked
about recently
so you can't have one man for one woman
and have everyone married
yeah most people can be monogamous but
there has to be some men
that are poligenous and at the end of
the at the end of the day just like ana
said
we're not perfect so if the man isn't
perfect if he's not on point
he's not going to be a man that has four
wives he's going to be one that probably
has one or none
because allah says don't even support
one if you can't even support one
so at the end of the day if he can
support four cool
but it's kind of crazy there was also a
hadith of the prophet saws
talking about how there will come a day
where the number of women will outnumber
men
indeed to the point where there are 50
women for one man
and y'all might think that's a stretch
bro but
well we got we got abortion being
rampant today and we got some
hardcore feminists out here literally
aborting men
or boys when they find out the gender of
the baby or the sex of the baby and they
keep it when it's a it's a girl
that's that's scary bro yeah it's 201 by
the way it's 201
perfect perfect we'll go to 205 but
we'll wrap it up now whenever you're
ready dude
if it gets to that appointment then
we're gonna have to have like 10 to 15
wives bro
so like hey congratulations you didn't
want us to have four now we're gonna
have 10 to 15.
and it's like bro that's that's
literally the point allah doesn't make
for as an arbitrary value y'all
feminists are looking at it from the
point where
today we have monogamy which is a social
construct that we created it
uh it's a liberal construct and because
we have monogamy
why did islam increase it to four it's
like bro islam never increased
to four because it was never one islam
decreased it to four
because if you look at the historicity
of the sun it was always
thousands it was always hundreds bro
there was some people like bro
genghis khan yeah he's not a muslim but
you guys know what i mean
um you know suleiman had what how many
wives
90 300 something like that i think
that's biblical i don't know if that's
islamic
but yeah by the way you got you got you
got what was it um
had so many wives that they couldn't
even keep count
you know or was it hamza i have no idea
peace be upon them both more power to
them both if they have that many wives
but you get what i mean and it's like
there's nothing wrong with that but
allah came down and said the quran and
with revelation
with re-establishing islam allah
decreased it and placed a limit
to four for the first time ever we
finally have a limit
it was never a limit before subhan allah
i always find it funny like i find it
funny that anybody
subjectively can come and say that it's
wrong and they're speaking like as if
they have this objective morality
because listen
it's not up to me to prove that what i'm
doing is is right
everything you can have one of two
things either everything is right until
proven wrong or everything is wrong till
proven right
right you can only have one or the other
you don't you don't have a country in
the world that gives you a list of
things you can do
they give you a list of laws that you
you know can't break they're things you
cannot do
right like you can't steal you can't
kill you can't they give you things
you can't do same thing with the stem
same thing with any religion it's just
commandments of things you can't do
because that's a lot
shorter of list which says a lot by the
way so it's up to you to show me why i
as a man cannot have multiple wives
past present future objectively as a
matter of fact
you cannot do that without objective
morality
therefore it cannot be done therefore
you have no right to speak on the issue
you can dislike it and hate it all you
want
but that at the end of the day if you
can't prove that it's wrong
then you have no basis for what you
believe you have to justify
it to me it might sound like we got we
got our feet on you next bro but it's
like
it's not we're not attacking ladies at
all it's like but what i'm finding a
trend is we got
a one two three four ish women that i
could think of that are hardcore
feminists in our comments
and then i look at the dislikes into one
two three four something like that
and it's like bro you already know who
it is yo and the last thing that i want
to say to you
is that a lot of uh these women and i'm
not referring to
the specific ones on my channel i'm
talking about in the entire world
brother they will say um well why can't
you be with one woman
it's like dude that's not the case like
we can damn well be
with one woman we've done it i've done
it
i'm sure most men in this world have
done it and are doing it i should say
there are very few men out here that are
politicians but it's like you know what
if it's permissible for me to have four
wives if i can support for wise if i can
treat them all
justly then why would i just settle
unless that one woman is equal
to those four women in value
which like i said it's very rare that
that happens and
dude if if a woman comes to me and she
shows me how much value she has
i'm not talking about talking i'm
talking about actually her actions
show me that she is equal
for a woman and she's just she is
on board like she is like uh hadija
khadijah
the the prophet peace be upon him his
first wife
she was like his backbone she supported
him with everything bro she was
on his team right or die
and like bro if a woman can prove that a
woman can show that
then bro
i will happily be with one
but if a woman cannot do that and it is
permissible for me and
i have the means to which i can do that
and actually bring
let's say 12 let's say 12 kids into this
world and have them be
such high value super human muslims
why would i choose not to do that just
to satisfy
this woman's emotions and this woman's
uh
well-being or her insecurities i should
say
see brother angel came into the world as
zero muslims
and now he's leaving with twelve leaving
behind twelve muslims how is that not
good in the la
in the eyes of allah ladies you can't be
out here wondering why you're not being
treated as a queen if you're
out here trying to be king don't forget
that barramundi
all right with that being said may allah
bless you all if you watched this long
then
comment what should they come at this
time feminist feminist
nah bro i'm a nazi no not feminazi
comment from the lives
you understand that there are things
that are more important than just the
the the the ups and downs and the
vicissitudes of life
right that you're going to go back to
allah and that's inevitable
you know and that constant you know
reminder of death
helps you spiritually because then it's
not about what does this person think
about me
how good do i look on instagram none of
that's gonna matter
right you don't take your toys with you
when you go right and you can have all
the toys you want
at the end the end is the end
[Music]
hmmm
[Music]